netflix is dying but not because their
shows aren't popular squid game was by
far the biggest show of 2021 but netflix
stock has lost 200 billion dollars in
value over just the last few months so
what's going on well the simple answer
is that netflix has stopped growing but
digging into the details tells a much
more complicated story see while it's
true that netflix isn't gaining new
subscribers anymore the reasons for the
slowdown are what we really need to
analyze here and interestingly i
recently found a young artificial
intelligence researcher who's building a
new technology that could completely
transform netflix as we know it and turn
them back into the tech powerhouse that
they once were so let's figure out why
netflix has lost two-thirds of its value
in just six months and create a plan for
how they can get back on top basically
everyone has a netflix account now and
that's actually part of the problem here
the last two years have forced millions
of people to spend more time inside and
netflix was a great option to stay sane
when you can't go out and do normal
activities this led to incredible growth
for netflix throughout 2020 and 2021 the
stock nearly doubled as everyone spent
more time streaming content from their
couches but this actually accelerated
one of the biggest problems for netflix
market saturation anyone who could
afford netflix and like streaming
content basically signed up over the
last two years initially most analysts
who looked at the massive growth in
netflix subscribers figured that these
people were subscribing just a bit
earlier than expected but the reality
was much worse these new subscribers
weren't merely pulled forward they were
essentially all of the remaining people
who would ever subscribe the team at
netflix began realizing that they had
essentially converted every possible
customer and growth had to slow down
their chief financial officer even
acknowledged this during their
end-of-year review overall the business
was healthy
retention was strong churn was down
viewing was up but on the margin we just
um we didn't grow acquisition quite as
fast as as we would have liked to see
then just a few months later netflix
announced that they actually lost
subscribers for the first time in over
10 years obviously it's difficult to
grow your subscriber base when pretty
much everyone already subscribes but
there are a few other problems they're
dealing with right now first people
share netflix accounts like crazy this
wasn't a problem back when netflix was
sending dvds through the mail but now
that you can just log in with a friend's
netflix password and watch whatever you
want why would you pay now netflix does
have a plan to deal with password
sharers but we'll get to that later a
potentially even bigger problem for
netflix is direct competition for years
netflix has been the king of streaming
and most big media companies have really
struggled to transition away from old
school tv programming but disney plus
completely changed that perception they
launched at the end of 2019 and already
have 130 million subscribers that's more
than half of netflix this is a big
problem because streaming content
doesn't have a network effect like
facebook or twitter if a netflix
customer cancels their subscription and
switches to disney plus it's not like
they're leaving a bunch of social
connections behind on netflix they can
just move over in an instant netflix
does have one major advantage though
they're a global company it helps to
look at a map here to understand what's
really going on see even though netflix
lost subscribers overall they actually
grew in the asia pacific region that
growth wasn't enough to offset losses in
america europe africa and the middle
east though the global nature of netflix
is a double-edged sword on the one hand
hit shows like squid game can become
international sensations and drive
growth for the entire platform but on
the other hand many countries don't have
as much disposable income to spend on
streaming services india is a great
example here average american incomes
are roughly 20 times higher than average
indian incomes but india has four times
the population it's clearly a big
opportunity but netflix has to develop
new pricing strategies if they want to
start growing significantly in india the
team at netflix will clearly need to
rethink their business model
significantly if they want to start
growing again but pricing is just a
small part of the puzzle when it comes
to winning over international customers
the vast majority of netflix content is
still created for english-speaking
audiences and that's a big problem if
you speak english you're talking to the
minority 20
of the world speaks english 80 does not
[ __ ] know what we're talking about
nas daily has generated billions of
views precisely because the content is
designed to be internationalized from
the start so every video we make on nasa
every course we put on academy every
video put on us daily we've built
software to take it and put subtitles in
a different language
independent content creators have
already started capitalizing on
international opportunities but netflix
is falling behind
sure they have subtitles for most shows
but considering the incredible
production value of every show they
publish it could be a lot better and
that's where that ai hacker i mentioned
earlier comes in his name is rich
pavlovsky and he's building a startup
that automatically translates video
content into different languages that
alone wouldn't be worth mentioning after
all squid game did have english dubs
even if they were terrible but rich is
planning to take video translations
several steps further using cutting edge
deep learning algorithms instead of just
layering a voice recording over existing
footage like most dubs do rich's company
blanc essentially uses deep fakes to
realign the mouth movements to match
what the new audio track sounds like
this solves that problem where the mouth
movements don't match up and creates a
much more natural and immersive
experience but how do you get here rich
has a fascinating backstory that
motivates everything he's working on now
he grew up in moscow russia and overcame
a remarkable set of obstacles to get to
where he is today rich had a natural
talent for math as a young kid and his
parents knew that he could go on to do
great things if he just had the right
resources there was a problem though
higher level exam prep and english
tutors aren't cheap and his parents
didn't want to see rich fall behind so
they sold their family car to pay for
his studies and make sure that he had
the opportunity to apply his skills that
gamble paid off and rich got accepted to
go study math and physics at the
university of toronto this was a huge
break for rich he'd taken some stanford
machine learning courses online but now
he was in the heart of one of the best
ai universities in the world but while
he was in college he realized something
that would permanently change his view
of the world sure rich clearly had an
innate affinity for solving technical
problems but if he hadn't learned
english he would have never been able to
understand what was going on in those
stanford online classes he'd gotten
lucky but for billions of people around
the world online education was still out
of reach he knew that he could change
this and ai was the perfect tool for the
job machine learning is actually like i
would say the closest thing to magic
that we have in our life it's like you
can if you can imagine it you probably
can guilt it the goal was clear in his
mind tons of valuable videos are already
out there they just need to be
translated into every possible language
it was a cool idea but he was still
working towards his college degree so it
had to stay a side project that was the
plan at least until economic factors
threw a wrench in all of that his
parents could no longer afford to help
him with tuition so he had to leave
university and get started immediately
but getting a startup off the ground is
never easy and rich knew this he built
small side projects in the past like a
3d printed prosthetic arm but scaling
video translation would be an entirely
new challenge he had to find an advisor
who was not just an expert in machine
learning but also a successful
entrepreneur luckily he found one in
aidan gomez aiden is the founder of
cohere ai which is one of the fastest
growing artificial intelligence
companies in the world now aiden is
clearly a talented entrepreneur he's
raised over 170 million dollars to date
but more importantly he's a world-class
expert in deep learning and had been
educating the world about the power of
neural networks for years a neural
network is just a program consisting of
a set of neurons which are wired
together at one end of the network we'll
feed in inputs
at the other end of the network will
receive outputs rich had assembled a
talented team to help make his dream a
reality so now it was time to build but
getting a functional product out the
door would be no easy task in order to
deliver fully automated translations
with proper lip syncing rich and his
team would essentially need to build
five systems at once for any video they
received they would first need to
transcribe the audio so that they knew
exactly what was being said then they'd
need to translate that text into the
target language once they had an
accurate translation they'd use machine
learning to paraphrase the script so the
words would match the original duration
see some sentences just take longer to
say when directly translated so they'd
have to account for this then once they
had a usable translation they'd need to
generate natural sounding speech and
lastly they need to actually change the
video frames so that the lips match up
with the new audio here's an example of
how that works in practice the
translation is something i wanted to ask
you about
and uh first just to give a shout out to
the supercomputer
now the results are clearly still a bit
rough around the edges but rich and his
team are making improvements every day
and most importantly since they're using
a deep learning approach the system will
get better as it's fed more and more
data with a working system in place rich
and his team went into user acquisition
mode but no one is going to give money
to a company without a name so they had
to come up with something that fit the
company they were building they settled
on the name blanc after the famous voice
over artist mel blanc who had voiced
bugs bunny daffy duck and porky pig
throughout the early 20th century
hollywood has come a long way since mel
blanc brought looney tunes to life with
his voice acting skills and it's about
to get a lot more fun for everyone we've
seen visual effects artists create
remarkably life-like facial animations
in films like star wars and the irishman
but this work is painstaking and time
intensive the results are amazing but
the traditional approach just won't
scale to meet the volume of video
content out there alexander wang is the
founder of scale ai and has a really
good rationale for thinking about when
to apply machine learning models if you
think about what tasks
humans are good at versus what tasks
algorithms are good at generally that
more or less boils down to data
availability which is that where there
are large pools of digital data an
algorithm can learn from and those pools
of digital data either have been
collected in the past or easy to collect
in the future those are going to be the
problems which
algorithms can do effectively and can
learn to do effectively and then areas
where there does not exist digital data
and is expensive to collect this digital
data those are going to be the last
things to be automated and we're already
seeing deep fakes have an impact on
filmmaking visual effects studios are
starting to use deep fakes to help make
actors look younger or even bring them
back from the dead rich is working on
making those ai enabled superpowers
available to everyone at ridiculously
low cost our mission is to solve
language barrier world worldwide if you
want to do this you need to um
you need your technology to be used by a
lot of people it needs to reach a lot of
people
and the best way to do it is to sell to
the platforms we don't want to compete
in terms of marketing his company is
still just starting to scale and they
aren't going to be able to deliver
hollywood level effects at the click of
a button just yet but by taking an ai
first approach and integrating into the
large video platforms they'll be able to
translate millions of hours of video
footage extremely quickly so how does
all of this affect netflix well they
should clearly start investing in ai
technologies to help further
internationalize their content library
every movie and tv show on netflix
should be available in any language with
perfect voice-over and lip movements
that actually match the dialogue it's
crystal clear that this technology is
coming the only question is if they can
find a way to implement it reliably at
scale implementing the technology that
rich and his team have built clearly
won't be enough though they're gonna
have to figure out how to deal with
people that share passwords and they
will probably need to launch a free tier
that has advertisements getting
households to upgrade their plans if
they really want to share accounts with
extended friends and family is pretty
straightforward but launching an ads
business will be another challenge
entirely to be fair the size of the
prize here is massive the global tv ad
market is 141 billion dollars and
youtube generated nearly 30 billion
dollars just last year if netflix gets
it right they could easily grow their
revenue significantly but netflix has
always had a premium brand and
differentiated itself from traditional
tv precisely because it didn't have ads
even though netflix would obviously
still offer ad-free streaming to paying
customers the mere existence of a free
tier would make the whole experience
feel different instead of paying for
exclusive content you're now just paying
to avoid ads and that isn't exactly in
line with the brand they've spent so
many years building developing the
software required to deliver relevant
ads anywhere in the world will also be a
big engineering effort so the risk here
is that netflix winds up only thinking
of the short term and misses the
importance of ai they clearly have
talented engineers on staff but if they
have their hands tied up on ads for the
next few years they might need to work
with a startup to solve their
translation problem and that creates an
opportunity netflix clearly has a long
road ahead but with a shrewd business
strategy and the latest ai technology
i'm optimistic that they can turn it
around and as for rich his company is
still thousands of times smaller than
netflix so it's a real david and goliath
situation but he doesn't actually have
to defeat any big companies to be
successful here as long as he stays
ahead of the curve everyone will want to
use blanc for video translation and if
you want to hear another story of a
talented founder using ai to build an
incredible company just go watch my
video about how one of the co-founders
of twitch built a self-driving car
company worth billions thanks for
watching